Good morning, afternoon or evening. You are watching public access with Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman and Will Arnett. This is not public, it's just like a regular podcast. And it's called SmartLess and it's a brand new episode and here we go. Welcome to SmartLess. Jason, we're doing this episode while you're in Atlanta right now and it looks like you're in a laundry room or you're in a closet. Yeah, it's, I'm in the closet. Go ahead, Will. Go ahead, do I tee that up high enough for you? Dude, no, no. It's too easy, right?
早上好，下午好，或者晚上好。你们正在收看由肖恩·海耶斯、杰森·贝特曼和威尔·阿奈特主持的公共频道节目。这不是公共节目，这只是一个普通的播客。它叫《SmartLess》，这是一期全新的节目，我们开始吧。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。杰森，我们录这期节目时你正在亚特兰大，看起来你是在洗衣房或者壁橱里。是的，我在壁橱里。继续吧，威尔。来吧，我给你铺垫得够好了吗？伙计，不，不。这太容易了，对吧？
That's low hanging fruit, which I want to point out at all times. Low hanging fruit, still fruit. So low hanging fruit and in the closet could actually be the same. Yeah, exactly. I thought you could combine those two pitches and really hit something deep. Yeah, no. Jason, were you the one telling me about the Formula One series? You were watching that, right, on Netflix there? I thought you, did you tell, somebody told me about that. It is unbelievable. I'm all, because I was never, I was like Formula One, who, I don't even know what that is. Kizzers and then started watching it, incredible. What is it?
那是唾手可得的果实，我得随时指出来。唾手可得的果实，那也是果实。所以“唾手可得的果实”和“在壁橱里”其实是一回事。是的，没错。我以为你可以把这两个梗结合起来，真的搞出点深刻的东西。是的，没有。杰森，是你跟我提过那个一级方程式系列赛吗？你在Netflix上看的那个，对吧？我以为你，是你告诉我的吗？有人跟我提过那个。简直不可思议。我完全，因为我以前从来没，我当时想一级方程式是什么，我甚至不知道那是什么。然后就开始看了，太棒了。那是什么？
It's incredible. Yeah, I got it. I got it. I got to get on that. What is it? It's a docu-series on Netflix about the Formula One season. And so now they've done three seasons. I don't know what that is. And a Formula One race car driving in Europe. Oh, I'm all in. Yeah.
太不可思议了。是的，我明白了。我明白了。我得去看看。那是什么？那是Netflix上关于一级方程式赛季的纪录片系列。他们已经拍了三季了。我不知道那是什么。还有在欧洲开的一级方程式赛车。哦，我完全入坑了。是的。
I'm all in. Honestly, Sean, you're safe. Holy crap. Wait, tell me the documentary about this, about driving cars. You're joking about it now. Wait till you watch. It is so incredible. These guys are unbelievable. I'm all F1 now. By the way, first of all, first and foremost, I'm FU, but then I'm F1. But speaking of odd sports to get addicted to, Will, I am enjoying the rekindled addiction that you've spawned in me with golf. Yeah, sure.
我完全入坑了。老实说，肖恩，你很安全。天哪。等等，告诉我关于这个纪录片的事，关于开车的。你现在是在开玩笑吧。等你看了就知道了。真的太不可思议了。这些人简直难以置信。我现在完全迷上F1了。顺便说一下，首先，最重要的是，我是FU（去你的），但之后我是F1。说到容易上瘾的奇怪运动，威尔，我很享受你激发的我对高尔夫重新燃起的瘾。是的，当然。
Sean, Will got me back into golf during COVID. Yeah. He got me into this podcast and into golf. Yeah. So, but I've just about 20 minutes ago realized my new bottom in this addiction, you know, people that are in addiction, you know, they say, oh, my bottom was when I, you know, slid off the highway and that got me into rehab. Sure. Okay. So I just found my bottom with golf 20 minutes ago, a bottom being a being an intentional pun.
肖恩，威尔在新冠疫情期间让我重新开始打高尔夫。是的。他让我开始听这个播客，还让我开始打高尔夫。是的。所以，大约20分钟前，我意识到我这种瘾的新低谷，你知道，那些有瘾的人，你知道，他们会说，哦，我的低谷是我，你知道，从高速公路上滑下去，然后我进了康复中心。当然。好吧。所以我20分钟前刚找到了打高尔夫的低谷，这个“低谷”是一个双关语。
I was sitting on the Johnny. Yep. And I was practicing my swing. Okay. Wall on the John. And I really was focused on sort of a wrist hinge and an elbow tuck thing. Hey, listen, Jason. And then I realized, wait, I'm late for the podcast.
我当时正坐在马桶上。是的。我在练习挥杆。好吧。在马桶上的时候。我真的专注于手腕的弯曲和手肘的内收。嘿，听着，杰森。然后我意识到，等等，我录播客要迟到了。
That's a true story. That's my, that's a new bottom. But here's the good news. You can look at it like that, or you can look at it like when it comes to golf, you give a shit. God, that's great. This is why you get paid so much money, Will. But wait, I knew you were like massive golfer during pandemic, but didn't you love it before that? I did, but not like this.
这是个真实的故事。那是我的，那是一个新的低谷。但好消息是。你可以那样看，或者你可以把它看作是当你开始打高尔夫时，你真的很在乎。天哪，太棒了。这就是你为什么能赚这么多钱的原因，威尔。但等等，我知道你在疫情期间是个超级高尔夫球手，但你之前不就喜欢它吗？我喜欢，但没像现在这样。
He quit. He quit for many years. Yeah. And then, then when I was, I called him up one day and I go, I go, let's go play golf. We played like three times and within, within three weeks we were at Pebble Beach. So that's how quickly it. I got it back. Accelerate.
他放弃了。他放弃了很多年。是的。然后，然后当我，有一天我给他打电话，我说，我说，我们去打高尔夫吧。我们大概打了三次，三周之内我们就到了圆石滩。所以这就是它恢复得有多快。我找回感觉了。加速。
I played once in Ireland with my brother, Kevin. And when I found out they didn't have carts, he had to walk everywhere. I was like, I'm out. I'm out. I'm not walking 18 miles. You should meet our friend, Josh. He goes the same way you do. I apologize to our tour surprise guest.
我和我哥哥凯文在爱尔兰打过一次。当我发现他们没有球车，他不得不走完全程时。我就想，我不干了。我不干了。我才不要走18英里。你应该见见我们的朋友乔什。他和你想的一样。我向我们今天的惊喜嘉宾道歉。
Oh, no, here we go. I'm telling a boring story and I was late. No, this, this, this girl, you're going to say hello to today. I think you all know, but is one of the loves of my life. She's a brilliant writer, a brilliant actress, a brilliant crafts woman, which she should turn into a superhero character. Does that mean crafts woman? Crafts woman. Does that mean smoking the, the jazz cigarettes?
哦，不，开始了。我在讲一个无聊的故事，而且我还迟到了。不，这个，这个女孩，你们今天要打招呼的，我想你们都知道，她是我的挚爱之一。她是一位出色的作家，一位出色的演员，一位出色的手工艺人，她应该把自己变成一个超级英雄角色。那是什么意思，手工艺人？手工艺人。那是指抽那种爵士香烟吗？
No, that's no. Okay. No jazz. She's a former member of second city. She started a million animated shows, a million movies, a million TV shows like broad city, difficult people, most notably as Jerry Blankens strangers with candy. And now the true TV series at home with Amy Sedaris. No way.
不，不是。好吧。没有爵士。她是第二城剧团的前成员。她开创了无数动画节目、无数电影、无数电视节目，比如《大城小妞》、《难搞的人》，最著名的是《带糖的陌生人》里的杰瑞·布兰肯。现在是True TV的系列剧《与艾米·塞德丽丝在家》。不会吧。
My gorgeous day for the day, the extremely limber. The queen. No way. Hello, Amy. Oh, look at her. Oh my God. Your conversation. It's terrible.
我今天的美女，极其灵活的。女王。不会吧。你好，艾米。哦，看看她。天哪。你们的对话。太糟糕了。
Was hilarious. It's dumb. First of all, that book, did you ever read John Daley's book, The Golfer? No. No. It's really good because the guy had zero boundaries. Yeah. And it's, he had crazy relationships, went through money.
太搞笑了。太蠢了。首先，那本书，你读过约翰·戴利的《高尔夫球手》那本书吗？没有。没有。它真的很好，因为这家伙完全没有界限。是的。而且它，他有疯狂的关系，挥霍钱财。
It's, it's a very entertaining book. Wait, but what are you doing reading? I highly recommend it. What are you doing reading a book on golfing? Are you, are you a closet golfer like me? No, my dad was a golfer, but I've read a lot. I like reading books about athletes and I read golf my way. Remember that book? What was that Jack Nick?
这，这是一本非常有趣的书。等等，你为什么要读？我强烈推荐它。你为什么要读一本关于高尔夫的书？你，你像我一样是个隐形高尔夫球手吗？不，我爸爸是个高尔夫球手，但我读过很多。我喜欢读关于运动员的书，我读过《我的高尔夫方式》。还记得那本书吗？那是谁写的？杰克·尼克劳斯。
Whatever his name is. Jack Nicholson. Really? Yeah. But the John Daley book is really worth picking up. Are you, are you a big sports fan? No, but I like watching documentaries about athletes. You talked about that race car.
不管他叫什么名字。杰克·尼科尔森。真的吗？是的。但约翰·戴利那本书真的值得一读。你，你是个大体育迷吗？不，但我喜欢看关于运动员的纪录片。你刚才提到了那辆赛车。
I'll watch it, but I watched the one about the Italian guy that was on HBO maybe. Did you watch the Bee Gees documentary? I did. I did watch the Bee Gees documentary. I wanted more from that. Anyway, hi guys. Hi. I want more athletes.
我会看的，但我看了HBO上关于那个意大利人的纪录片，也许吧。你看过比吉乐队的纪录片吗？我看过。我看过比吉乐队的纪录片。我想要更多那样的内容。总之，嘿，伙计们。嘿。我想要更多运动员。
Sean, they're not athletes. But I'm just saying like, why would you go to the Bee Gees? Just things that I wouldn't normally watch. Like I didn't care about that. Because the word documentary triggered it. I know. That's why. You know what?
肖恩，他们不是运动员。但我只是说，你为什么会去看比吉乐队？只是我平时不会看的东西。就像我根本不在乎那个。因为“纪录片”这个词触发了它。我知道。就是这样。你知道吗？
I want to say something. This is interesting. You bring it up. There's something about these days when you say documentary now, people feel like it's a substitute for reading. So they go like, I watch lots of documentaries. Like as if that makes them smart. I'm like, who gives a shit?
我想说点什么。这很有趣。你提到了这一点。现在当你提到纪录片时，人们觉得这是一种阅读的替代品。所以他们会说，我看了很多纪录片。好像这让他们显得很聪明。我就想，谁在乎呢？
You were watching TV. Yeah. Big deal. And I want to say, I understand watching documentaries. I still don't understand sitting down and reading for pleasure. Incredible. Reading for recreation. But Amy, you take it to a whole new level by reading about something
你在看电视。是的。大不了。我想说，我理解看纪录片。我仍然不理解为了消遣而坐下来阅读。不可思议。为了娱乐而阅读。但艾米，你把它提升到了一个全新的高度，通过阅读一些
that's not even on your passion. And it's about a guy who God bless John Daly, but he's not currently racing for the championship right now. He's sort of, but I guess maybe that's what was interesting about the book is what's going on with him now kind of thing. Well, it's interesting about the book is that he had zero boundaries. He couldn't help himself. He had no control.
甚至不是你热衷的东西。而且是关于一个家伙，上帝保佑约翰·戴利，但他目前并没有在争夺冠军。他有点，但我猜也许这就是这本书有趣的地方，关于他现在的情况之类的。好吧，这本书有趣的地方在于他完全没有界限。他无法控制自己。他没有自控力。
And with the funny part is his wife stabbed him in the arm, the hand with a fork at the dinner table. She went to prison. It's just like, it's just crazy, crazy shit. It sounds good. Yeah, it really is. And like I said, it's not well written, but you know, he has two pages of just like non sequitur words that come to his mind.
有趣的部分是他的妻子在餐桌上用叉子刺了他的手。她进了监狱。这简直是，太疯狂了，太疯狂了。听起来不错。是的，确实如此。就像我说的，它写得并不好，但你知道，他有两页纸全是那种他脑子里冒出来的毫无关联的词。
But it's okay. Amy, not well. You tried writing a book half in the bag. You know what I mean? I mean, that's nuts. No, I mean, he's not a writer and that makes it even more entertaining. It's not like, But he's honest though.
但没关系。艾米，写得不好。你试过喝得半醉写书吗？你知道我的意思吗？我是说，那太疯狂了。不，我是说，他不是作家，这让它更具娱乐性。不像，但他很诚实。
Yeah. Okay. He's honest. It was really cool seeing him play with his son at that father's son tournament a few months ago. That was great. I don't know if you guys saw that. I did.
是的。好吧。他很诚实。几个月前看到他和他的儿子在那个父子锦标赛上打球真的很酷。那太棒了。我不知道你们有没有看到。我看到了。
I missed. I missed that. Oh yeah, sons. It's great golf. That one she missed. Amy, first of all, thank you for being here today. You're so nice to join us. Very, very nice.
我错过了。我错过了那个。哦，是的，儿子们。那是很棒的高尔夫。那个她错过了。艾米，首先，谢谢你今天能来。你太好了，能加入我们。非常，非常感谢。
Thank you for having me. Yeah. Yeah. And other than us barging in on, on your life today, what, I think I speak for lots of people when like, what is a typical Saturday, for example, look like at Amy Sideris's apartment? Like what do you, how do you occupy your free time? Because I feel like you're always going. I am always going.
谢谢你们邀请我。是的。是的。除了我们今天闯入你的生活之外，我想，我代表很多人问，比如，艾米·塞德丽丝的公寓里一个典型的周六是什么样的？你，你平时怎么打发空闲时间？因为我觉得你总是忙个不停。我总是忙个不停。
I have a lot of chores. I have a rabbit. So I've got hay to deal with. I've got constantly vacuuming. And then today I had a stretching class before this. I work out with a lady every Saturday. It's, it's a stretching class. They teach you how to stretch.
我有很多家务。我有一只兔子。所以我得处理干草。我得不停地吸尘。然后今天在录这个之前我上了一节拉伸课。我每周六都和一个女士一起锻炼。这，这是一节拉伸课。他们教你怎么拉伸。
Well, yeah, you're just reaching for the stars. So, so I did that before. Do you sweat in that class? Is it as annoying as yoga where you sweat just cause you're stretching? It calms me down. It's good for me. It's a good, you know, I just do it every Saturday morning from 11 to 12. Just cause I'm curious, what are the plastic bags hanging in the back?
好吧，是的，你只是在向星星伸手。所以，所以我之前做了那个。你在那节课上出汗吗？它像瑜伽一样烦人吗，就是因为你在拉伸所以出汗？它让我平静下来。它对我很好。它很好，你知道，我每周六早上11点到12点都做。只是因为我好奇，后面挂着的塑料袋是什么？
I'm obsessed with those. Plastic bags? I'm trying to go bigger on that screen. Costumes. Oh, customs a lot. They're gingham dress bags. I had a friend make me. So it's like wardrobe.
我迷上那些了。塑料袋？我正试着在屏幕上放大看。戏服。哦，很多戏服。那是格子连衣裙袋子。我让一个朋友帮我做的。所以就像衣橱一样。
This is my dress up room. This is where I come to get ready for events. And I do zoom calls from here. Oh nice. Wait a second. Are you going to enough events to dedicate an entire room for prep? No, I actually live in the apartment downstairs and this is my playroom. They're not attached.
这是我的装扮室。这是我为活动做准备的地方。我从这里打Zoom电话。哦，不错。等等。你参加的活动多到需要专门腾出一个房间来准备吗？不，我其实住在楼下的公寓里，这是我的游戏室。它们不相连。
The apartments aren't attached. I just got it because I didn't want anyone above me. I get that. It's like the writer's room. And you love New York. You love New York. You don't ever want to move from there. Is that where you're going to die?
公寓不相连。我买下它只是因为我不想要任何人住在我上面。我懂了。这就像编剧室。而且你爱纽约。你爱纽约。你不想从那里搬走。那是你要终老的地方吗？
We're going to have to like discover you in a pile of yarn and glue. I mean, I like the energy of New York city. I kind of need it because I live by myself and I need that stimulation. It's like when I go to North Carolina or Los Angeles, I just don't know. Coffee just isn't enough. You know, I just, it's just, I don't, I'm not stimulated. How often are you seeing Justin Thoreau? I saw him last night and he said to say hello to all of you.
我们得像在纱线和胶水堆里发现你一样。我是说，我喜欢纽约市的活力。我有点需要它，因为我一个人住，我需要那种刺激。就像我去北卡罗来纳州或洛杉矶时，我就是不知道。咖啡根本不够。你知道，我只是，我没有受到刺激。你多久见一次贾斯汀·塞洛克斯？我昨晚见到他了，他说向你们所有人问好。
Five days a week maybe? You guys are very close, right? I haven't seen him in a while, but I did. I saw him last night and told him I was doing this and he's like, why they have never asked me to do it. That sounds like him. That sounds like him. Sleeves or no sleeves?
一周五天吗？你们关系很近，对吧？我有一段时间没见他了，但我确实见到了。我昨晚见到他，告诉他我要做这个，他说，为什么他们从来没邀请我去做？听起来像他。听起来像他。有袖子还是没袖子？
Last night. Last night. No sleeves. He had no sleeves. Oh God bless. What does that mean? No sleeves. He cut off.
昨晚。昨晚。没袖子。他没穿袖子。哦，上帝保佑。那是什么意思？没袖子。他剪掉了。
And Selena was on the cover. Oh really? It's got to be, it's got to be snowing for him to Velcro sleeve time. I thought about giving him, and I told him this for his birthday, like three years ago, I was just going to give him a nice wrap box and he opened it up and it was just a box full of sleeves. Yeah. Different colors, different textures.
而且赛琳娜在封面上。哦，真的吗？他一定是，他一定是到了穿魔术贴袖子的天气了。我考虑过送他，我三年前在他生日时告诉过他，我打算送他一个漂亮的包装盒，他打开一看，里面全是袖子。是的。不同的颜色，不同的质地。
Because he obviously doesn't have any. No, beer cozy. Let me tell you something. If I had those guns. I know, I know. We're just jealous. Well, we're going to see a lot of them because he's doing press now for Mosquito Coast and he's got his muscles out for every,
因为他显然没有袖子。不，啤酒保温套。让我告诉你一件事。如果我有那些肌肉。我知道，我知道。我们只是嫉妒。好吧，我们会经常看到他，因为他现在正在为《蚊子海岸》做宣传，他把肌肉露出来给每一张，
every picture he has sent me. He's in white jeans or has big muscles. You know what's great? You know what's crazy Sean? So you have, Amy's your guest here. You introduce her, you give all their credit, all these great things. We did, I don't know, six, seven seasons of Bojack. I never saw Amy once.
他发给我的每一张照片。他穿着白牛仔裤或者有大块肌肉。你知道什么很棒吗？你知道什么很疯狂吗，肖恩？所以你有，艾米是你的嘉宾。你介绍她，你给了她所有的赞誉，所有这些伟大的事情。我们做了，我不知道，六、七季的《马男波杰克》。我一次都没见过艾米。
No, through the pilot we saw each other. That's it. What do you mean? How does that work so you guys don't see each other when you record? Oh my God, this TCA is going great by the way. We don't know. We would do table reads and the best part would be on the table read. Everybody else was in Los Angeles around this table.
不，在试播集我们见过面。就那样。你是什么意思？你们录音的时候怎么会见不到面？天哪，这个TCA（电视评论家协会）进行得真好。我们不知道。我们会做剧本朗读，最棒的部分会在剧本朗读上。其他所有人在洛杉矶围着这张桌子。
Everybody else. Everybody except for Amy and Amy every once in a while, somebody else would have to call in because they were out of town, whatever. But Amy would be on a speakerphone in the middle and the speakerphone was right in front of me. Most of it, like 99% of the time. And Paul Tomkins and I sat next to each other and we were just waiting
其他所有人。除了艾米，艾米偶尔，其他人不得不打电话进来，因为他们不在城里，什么的。但艾米会在中间开着免提，免提就在我面前。大部分时间，99%的时间。保罗·汤普金斯和我坐在一起，我们只是在等，
because Amy would also sometimes just as a, you know, to help out, she'd do other voices and she'd really commit to these other voices. Yeah. And she was so, and Paul Tomkins and I were waiting. We were like, who's going to come up next? Your overseas operator whole place. But then I never got to do them in the recording. I'm like, come on.
因为艾米有时也会，你知道，为了帮忙，她会做其他声音，她真的会投入到这些声音里。是的。她太，保罗·汤普金斯和我在等。我们当时想，下一个会是谁？你的海外接线员，整个地方。但我从来没在录音里做过它们。我当时想，来吧。
It's my operator voice. No. Like, no. Just do Princess Carolyn is Caroline. I didn't even know my name. But I would have to be on hold like 10 minutes hearing you guys laugh in the room and you're laughing and talking. And I'm just like, why don't we just start 50 minutes late?
那是我的接线员声音。不。像，不。就做卡罗琳公主。我甚至不知道我的名字。但我不得不保持通话状态大概10分钟，听着你们在房间里笑，你们在笑和说话。我当时就想，为什么我们不晚15分钟开始？
It was, and there was a delay. So sometimes I wanted to laugh, but it would just interrupt your, you know, you guys reading it. You were so good though with the delay and everything. And you were so, I mean, I can't imagine because again, the speaker was right in front of me. I was such a loud mouth. You must have been, it must have been exhausting with the delay
那是，而且有延迟。所以有时我想笑，但这会打断你们，你知道，你们读剧本。你真的很棒，尽管有延迟什么的。而且你太，我是说，我无法想象，因为再说一次，扬声器就在我面前。我真是个大嘴巴。你一定，有延迟一定很累人，
and me barking my voice out at you. You did bark your voice, but it's such a, you have such a great voice and you were so good in that part. I mean, Oh God. Wait. So I, I love reading, you know, obviously you and your brother's books are great cause he talks a little bit about you guys growing up
还有我对着你大喊大叫。你确实大喊大叫了，但你声音太棒了，你在那个角色里表现得太好了。我是说，天哪。等等。所以我，我喜欢阅读，你知道，显然你和你哥哥的书很棒，因为他谈到了一些你们成长过程中的事，
and everything. And I love those stories about you and, and, and those early years. Talk a little bit of, cause I don't really know like how, what was that move like from North Carolina to Chicago to go do second city? Like how did that all go down? Well, I was wager scene in North Carolina in Royal 8th Capitol and David went to the art institute and he said,
还有一切。我喜欢那些关于你，和，和，那些早年的故事。谈谈，因为我真的不知道，从北卡罗来纳州搬到芝加哥去参加第二城剧团是什么样的？这一切是怎么发生的？好吧，我在北卡罗来纳州做服务员，在皇家国会大厦，大卫去了艺术学院，他说，
Oh, there's a place here called second city. And I think you'd be perfect for it because you're kind of writing on your feet. You do characters. You make things up on the spot. He goes, you should come here and do a workshop. So I did and I loved it. So I ended up staying and I took classes and then I got in the touring company and then I got a main stage, but that's where I met like Colbert
哦，这里有个地方叫第二城。我觉得你很适合那里，因为你很擅长即兴创作。你做角色。你当场编东西。他说，你应该来这里参加一个研讨会。所以我去了，我爱上了它。所以我最后留了下来，我上了课，然后我进了巡回演出公司，然后我进了主舞台，但我在那里遇到了像科尔伯特，
and Daniello and Tim Meadows. So that's kind of, that's where we all met. And then your goal is to find people that you work well with there. And then I'm just so glad that I still work with Paul and Stephen. Of course. And you guys had such an incredible run together. And, but you, so it wasn't like you're in North Carolina and like, this is my dream and I got to get to Chicago and bubble.
和丹尼洛，还有蒂姆·梅多斯。所以这就是，我们在那里相遇的地方。然后你的目标是找到和你合作得很好的人。然后我很高兴我仍然和保罗、斯蒂芬合作。当然。你们在一起度过了一段不可思议的时光。但是你，所以并不是说你在北卡罗来纳州，然后，这是我的梦想，我必须去芝加哥之类的。
It was just kind of your brother called and you're like, yeah, okay, shit, I'll come over there. Well, it was cause I never, I don't, David always says that, oh, you would have moved even if I hadn't said anything to you, but I don't know if I would. I'm just kind of content in North Carolina, trying to be a funny waitress and, you know, kind of just, I didn't mind it. I liked, I liked the weather.
只是你哥哥打了电话，你就说，是的，好吧，该死，我会去那里的。好吧，是因为我从来没，我不，大卫总是说，哦，即使我没跟你说什么，你也会搬走的，但我不知道我会不会。我在北卡罗来纳州挺满足的，努力做一个有趣的服务员，你知道，有点，我不介意。我喜欢，我喜欢天气。
I liked the people. I liked the Southern hospitality. Did you have your heart set on, on going into entertainment or do you, do you guys sometimes think about, had you stayed in the last city you lived in where your life would have gone? Like what do you think you would have been doing had you stayed in North Carolina? I either would have worked in a woman's prison or I would have gone to the police academy to be a police officer.
我喜欢那里的人。我喜欢南方的好客。你有没有下定决心进入娱乐业，或者你，你们有时会想，如果你留在了你住的最后一个城市，你的生活会变成什么样？你觉得如果你留在北卡罗来纳州，你会做什么？我要么会在女子监狱工作，要么会去警察学院当警察。
Oh, is that true? Is that true? I would have loved you. Or I was interested in being a social worker cause I like listening to other people's problems, you know, we're going into homes that I would never go into. And so I was fascinated by that. Because you wanted to help them or because it made you always feel better about your current state?
哦，那是真的吗？那是真的吗？我会爱死你的。或者我对当社会工作者很感兴趣，因为我喜欢听别人的问题，你知道，走进我永远不会去的家庭。所以我对此很着迷。因为你想帮助他们，还是因为这让你对自己目前的状态感觉更好？
Wanted me to feel better about my current state. That's the problem with, with some therapist I hear, you know, that's not necessarily altruism. It's just that they want to feel better about how crappy their life is by hearing problems that are worse than theirs. I didn't have, I just, I just like to hear other people's problems. I don't know. But then I was like, well, I can act like those people.
想让我对自己目前的状态感觉更好。这就是问题所在，有些治疗师我听说，你知道，那不一定是利他主义。只是他们想通过听比他们更糟糕的问题，来让自己对糟糕的生活感觉更好。我没有，我只是，我只是喜欢听别人的问题。我不知道。但后来我想，好吧，我可以扮演那些人。
But I was always, you know, I did plays and I was interested in entertaining and we would go to convalescent homes and do shows. My family and that was, I mean, I liked showbiz. And then TV kind of fell in my lap. We were doing plays in New York city. And then someone approached Paul and I and said, why don't you do a sketch show for HBO downtown? So it kind of just fell into our laps.
但我一直，你知道，我演戏，我对娱乐感兴趣，我们会去疗养院表演。我的家人，那是，我是说，我喜欢演艺圈。然后电视节目就掉进了我的怀里。我们在纽约演戏。然后有人接近保罗和我，说，为什么你们不在HBO市中心做一个小品节目？所以它就掉进了我们的怀里。
And that was, what was it called? Exhibit seven endless sketches, like eight minute sketches. It was like, I remember that show. Speaking of Stephen Colbert, can you please, please tell us an embarrassing story about him? I was not embarrassing. He threw up once in the parking lot of Wiener circle where he had to take his tie and pull it aside and vomit.
那是什么，它叫什么？《第七展览》，无尽的小品，像八分钟的小品。我记得那个节目。说到斯蒂芬·科尔伯特，你能请，请告诉我们一个关于他的尴尬故事吗？我不是尴尬。他在维纳圈的停车场吐过一次，他不得不把领带拉到一边呕吐。
Was it because of what he ate at Wiener circle? Yeah. He was drinking and then he got something to eat at Wiener circle and then he threw up in the parking lot, which was so out of character for him. But I remember making him laugh on stage one night. He was kind of, he was a little serious. He wanted to be a dramatic actor. And then we were doing a song on the stage and I put in some icky teeth, you know,
是因为他在维纳圈吃的东西吗？是的。他喝了酒，然后在维纳圈吃了点东西，然后他在停车场吐了，这对他来说太不符合性格了。但我记得有天晚上我在舞台上逗他笑。他有点，他有点严肃。他想成为一名戏剧演员。然后我们在舞台上唱歌，我戴了一些恶心的牙齿，你知道，
and I turned around and revealed him and he laughed. And then after the show, he got really angry and he went in the bathroom. He locked himself in the bathroom and he was so mad that he laughed. But then after that, we always cracked up on stage and he laughed. It's kind of like he came to our side and then he was really silly and goofy. Is that what led to him drinking so much at the Wiener circle? Then he tried to kill the feelings and then he threw up. Coming on this show feels like joining a Wiener circle a little bit.
我转过身露出他，他笑了。演出结束后，他非常生气，他进了浴室。他把自己锁在浴室里，他很生气自己笑了。但那之后，我们总是在舞台上笑个不停，他也笑了。就像他来到了我们这边，然后他变得非常傻，非常笨拙。这就是导致他在维纳圈喝那么多的原因吗？然后他试图杀死那些感觉，然后他吐了。来这个节目感觉有点像加入维纳圈。
It is. It must feel like that. Wow. The first idea was it to do this podcast. The world's. The world contacted us. And do you do it every Saturday? And do you ever be like, oh, I can't believe I have to do this?
是的。一定感觉像那样。哇。第一个想法是做这个播客。世界。世界联系了我们。你每周六都做吗？你有没有过，哦，我不敢相信我必须做这个？
Like I just said on your shoulders and you know, it's so embarrassingly easy. It's so easy and fun. Yeah, we just, we got to do it. I was going to, I was thinking about doing one and then I told Jason and then he and Sean were having dinner and Jason said, Will is doing a podcast. We should do that and get in on it. And then they called me and they bullied me and they said,
就像我刚才在你的肩膀上说的，你知道，这太尴尬地容易了。这太容易也太有趣了。是的，我们只是，我们必须做。我本来打算，我正在考虑做一个，然后我告诉了杰森，然后他和肖恩在吃晚饭，杰森说，威尔正在做一个播客。我们应该做那个，加入进去。然后他们给我打电话，他们欺负我，他们说，
we're joining your podcast. Oh, that's perfect. I would say we asked Will to join his podcast without a question mark. But wait, but Will, wasn't your, Will, your podcast was not going to be this though, was it? It wasn't going to be this. It was going to be something else. And then how did we come up with this?
我们要加入你的播客。哦，那太完美了。我会说我们问威尔加入他的播客时没有加问号。但等等，但是威尔，不是你的，威尔，你的播客本来不是这样的，对吧？它本来不是这样的。它本来是别的东西。然后我们是怎么想出这个的？
I mean, this isn't much of a concept, but I don't remember us. Did we just say we're going to do a podcast and then what do we do? Do we just the three of us talk or should we talk to other people? We were tossing around. Yeah, sort of. Now, by the way, now, Amy, this is your dream scenario. Now you're just listening to other people's problems. Great.
我是说，这没什么概念，但我不记得我们了。我们只是说我们要做一个播客，然后我们做什么？我们三个人谈话，还是我们应该和别人谈话？我们当时在讨论。是的，有点。现在，顺便说一下，现在，艾米，这是你的梦想场景。现在你只是在听别人的问题。太棒了。
Yeah. These are the problems you're talking about, right? Your podcast problems. Can I tell you something speaking of problems? One of the funniest things that, one of the things that made me laugh the most was years ago when I was, when I was with my ex-wife and we were together and we, we read this interview that Amy Sedaris did where she said,
是的。这些就是你谈论的问题，对吧？你的播客问题。我能告诉你一件事吗，说到问题？最有趣的事情之一，让我笑得最厉害的事情之一是几年前，当我，当我还是和我的前妻在一起的时候，我们在一起，我们读了艾米·塞德丽丝做的那个采访，她说，
she said that something, they were asking about getting mixed up with other people. And Amy Sedaris said, well, sometimes people mix me up with Amy Polar. And then they asked me how I'm doing. And I just say, it's okay, but Will and I are having a lot of problems. Sexual.
她说，他们问到和别人混淆的事情。艾米·塞德丽丝说，嗯，有时人们把我和艾米·波勒搞混了。然后他们问我过得怎么样。我就说，还可以，但威尔和我有很多问题。性方面的。
Sexual. Just sexual. But we get along great. Which we read in a magazine and I nearly, I nearly, I nearly threw up from laughing so hard. Because I thought it was such a funny bit to do. And then what happened?
性方面的。只是性方面的。但我们相处得很好。我们在杂志上读到这个，我差点，我差点，我差点笑吐了。因为我觉得这是一个非常有趣的梗。然后发生了什么？
Amy, you seemed to like, you know, I love you and I've known you for a long time. And you seem to have nailed that thing that makes comedy comedy, which is like, surprise. Like you always, your humor comes from such a like left of center, like lack of a better way to describe it, but more like unusual non-traditional place, you know what I mean?
艾米，你似乎，你知道，我爱你，我认识你很久了。你似乎已经掌握了让喜剧成为喜剧的东西，那就是，惊喜。就像你总是，你的幽默来自一个非常，左侧的，像没有更好的方式来描述它，但更像是不寻常的、非传统的地方，你知道我的意思吗？
But then you love sitcoms and like oldie timey programs. Oldie timey. You know what I mean? So like where, what are you? Mary Pickford. What were some of your favorite shows and stuff when you were growing up? Well, Laughin was a big one for me.
但你又喜欢情景喜剧和老派节目。老派。你知道我的意思吗？所以，你是谁？玛丽·皮克福德。你成长过程中最喜欢的一些节目是什么？嗯，《Laugh-In》对我来说是一个很大的节目。
I liked Jonathan Winners and Peter Sellers. I'm dating myself, I know. But I always loved SCTV more than Saturday Night Live because I was really, I liked their sets. Because it looked like they just made them or they were so cheap, you know, doors would swing open or nobody knew. And I, you know, and I loved all the characters on it.
我喜欢乔纳森·温特斯和彼得·塞勒斯。我知道我在暴露年龄。但我一直比《周六夜现场》更喜欢《SCTV》，因为我真的很喜欢他们的布景。因为看起来他们只是自己做的，或者它们太便宜了，你知道，门会摇晃，或者没人知道。而且我，你知道，我喜欢上面的所有角色。
When I was a kid, we have extended family who lived in San Diego when I'm from Chicago. And we flew out and they drove us up to see a taping of Laughin. Oh, wow. And I was like five. And I'm told it's the same stage as Will and Grace. Oh, really?
我小时候，我们有远房亲戚住在圣地亚哥，我来自芝加哥。我们飞过去，他们开车带我们去看《Laugh-In》的录制。哦，哇。我当时五岁。有人告诉我那和《威尔和格蕾丝》是同一个舞台。哦，真的吗？
Is that weird? Oh, wow. Yeah. Carol Burnett, of course. Carol Burnett was a big one too. I mean, who didn't love Carol Burnett or I Love Lucy, The Flintstones. But David was the biggest influence on me.
那很奇怪吗？哦，哇。是的。卡罗尔·伯内特，当然。卡罗尔·伯内特也是一个大人物。我是说，谁不喜欢卡罗尔·伯内特，或者《我爱露西》，《摩登原始人》。但大卫是对我影响最大的人。
Wait a second. The Flintstones. The Flintstones. Oh, and Jerry Lewis. Oh my God. I love Jerry Lewis. He really made me laugh. Now, Amy, do you enjoy the writing part more
等等。《摩登原始人》。《摩登原始人》。哦，还有杰瑞·刘易斯。天哪。我爱杰瑞·刘易斯。他真的让我笑了。现在，艾米，你更喜欢写作部分
than the performing part or vice versa? I'm not a writer really. I'm in a writer's room. I'm better. I can bring in ideas and I can get up on my feet and act it out and come up with stuff. But I don't sit in front of a computer and type. So I don't really consider myself.
还是表演部分，反之亦然？我不是真正的作家。我在编剧室。我更好。我可以带来想法，我可以站起来表演出来，想出东西。但我不会坐在电脑前打字。所以我并不真的认为自己是。
So I like to find things and performing them. And I like character driven things. Like when someone says, oh, just use your own voice or be yourself. I'm like, I don't even know how to do that. But you know, speaking of characters, and here we go, these guys are going to go to town on this. We're ready.
所以我喜欢寻找东西并表演它们。我喜欢以角色为导向的东西。就像当有人说，哦，只要用你自己的声音或者做你自己。我就想，我甚至不知道怎么做。但你知道，说到角色，开始了，这些家伙要大干一场了。我们准备好了。
But I love The Mandalorian. I love everything Star Wars. Oh my God, The Mandalorian. Yes. So you're so good on that show. I love that show. I didn't know you were on that show. Yeah.
但我喜欢《曼达洛人》。我喜欢《星球大战》的一切。天哪，《曼达洛人》。是的。你在那个节目里太棒了。我喜欢那个节目。我不知道你在那个节目里。是的。
She's amazing. And that show is one of the biggest shows in the world, right? I know. So are you or were you as big of a Star Wars fan as me? Or was this just like another gig? And I'm guessing you connected with Jon Favreau because of Elf and other things. Yeah, Favreau is very nice to me.
她太棒了。而且那个节目是世界上最伟大的节目之一，对吧？我知道。所以你，或者你像我一样是《星球大战》的粉丝吗？还是这只是另一个工作？我猜你是因为《精灵总动员》和其他事情和乔恩·费儒建立了联系。是的，费儒对我很好。
He puts me, he always calls me up and asks me to do things. But when he asked me to do this Mandalorian, I was like, oh, there's no way. I can't even pronounce these words. I had no idea you were coming out and you came out. I was like, holy shit, that's Amy. Oh my God. It was so cool to see you in that show.
他把我，他总是打电话给我，让我做事情。但当他让我做这个《曼达洛人》时，我就想，哦，不可能。我甚至发不出这些词的音。我不知道你要出来，你出来了。我就想，天哪，那是艾米。天哪。在那个节目里看到你太酷了。
It's fun to do it. I don't know what I'm saying. And I memorize it like word for word. And then it just kind of comes out because I don't know, I don't know where I am. They're like, you're on Tatooine. I'm like, no, you don't, it doesn't matter. What type of character do you play on Tatooine?
做这个很有趣。我不知道我在说什么。我把它背得一字不差。然后它就出来了，因为我不知道，我不知道我在哪里。他们说，你在塔图因。我就想，不，你不知道，这不重要。你在塔图因扮演什么类型的角色？
I'm a mechanic. So I have to, a lot of technical. And then my, first thing I said, I could just take my eyebrows off. Just, just lose my eyebrows. And they gave me a mullet. So I like my look. The costume's really tight so I can't bend over or anything.
我是个机械师。所以我必须，很多技术性的东西。然后我的，我说的第一件事，我可以把我的眉毛去掉。只是，只是去掉我的眉毛。他们给了我一个鲻鱼头。所以我喜欢我的造型。戏服真的很紧，所以我不能弯腰什么的。
It's really limiting. But I'm proud of myself that I can memorize those lines and not have any clue what I'm saying. And then Favreau will explain it to me, but I'm like, you're, it's. I love it. I love it. I wish John had said to you like, you're a, you're a mechanic and you're like, where?
这真的很受限。但我为自己能背下那些台词而感到自豪，而且完全不知道自己在说什么。然后费儒会向我解释，但我会说，你，这是。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我希望乔恩对你说过，你是一个，你是一个机械师，你就像，在哪里？
Tatooine. What part of Tatooine? Yeah. Where are you talking? The south side. Well, he said I'm a ship mechanic. And then when I got there, I was like, oh, a spaceship. That's how bad I am.
塔图因。塔图因的哪个部分？是的。你在哪里说话？南区。好吧，他说我是个飞船机械师。然后当我到那里时，我就想，哦，飞船。我就是这么糟糕。
I thought ship, like a ship. You know, I didn't know you could call a spaceship a ship. I was like, oh, okay. But I love the sets. I love the costumes, hair and makeup. It really is like a completely different world. And it's pretty cool. And I got to use old prompts.
我以为飞船，像一艘船。你知道，我不知道你可以把宇宙飞船叫作飞船。我就想，哦，好吧。但我喜欢布景。我喜欢戏服，发型和化妆。它真的就像一个完全不同的世界。而且很酷。我得用旧的提示。
But you know, well, I watch your Lego show. Oh, you do? Yes, I do. I watch it with my God kids. And you're always better when you have a guest come on. You have somebody to play with all of a sudden your whole, you know, I was on it once. He cut me out.
但你知道，威尔，我看你的乐高节目。哦，你看吗？是的，我看。我和我的教子一起看。当你有一个嘉宾来的时候，你总是表现得更好。你有人可以一起玩，突然间你的整个，你知道，我上过一次。他把我剪掉了。
That's a true story. Yeah. Oh, I don't remember seeing you on there. Yeah. No. Jason came to visit with his daughter with, with Maple. And, um, and they were like, should we, we mic him? And I said, no.
这是个真实的故事。是的。哦，我不记得在上面看到过你。是的。不。杰森带着他的女儿，带着梅普尔来参观。然后，他们说，我们要给他戴麦克风吗？我说，不。
And it was all unusable. We didn't use it. But thank you. You know what? That's a very, that's a, gosh, you really know what you're talking about. Amy. I know what I'm talking about. And the Lego movie, which I, you know, you're so good in.
而且全都没法用。我们没用它。但谢谢你。你知道吗？那是一个非常，天哪，你真的很了解你在说什么。艾米。我知道我在说什么。还有《乐高大电影》，我，你知道，你在里面表现得很好。
Well, thank you. But it's hard to do those kinds of things when you're, when you're doing a show like that and you're the one who's kind of got to keep it moving. Like you don't have somebody to do it with. And you have to be sincere because the people that are building stuff are, I mean, they're passionate about it. So you kind of, you kind of have to be that way too.
好吧，谢谢。但当你做那样的节目时，很难做那种事情，而且你是那种必须让它继续下去的人。就像你没有人和你一起做。而且你必须真诚，因为那些建造东西的人，我是说，他们对它充满热情。所以你有点，你有点也必须那样。
Yeah. And you don't want to, I, you know, I want to, I want to mess around all the time and do bit, you know, the stuff that gets cut out is stuff where I just go too far. Because. Well, you're hurting these, these adults feelings that are playing with toys. I've done it a few times, but, but it's mainly cause I'm just trying to have fun. And I always just, anytime I go into any kind of set,
是的。而且你不想，我，你知道，我想要，我想要一直胡闹，做梗，你知道，被剪掉的东西是我做得太过分了。因为。好吧，你在伤害这些，这些玩玩具的成年人的感情。我做过几次，但，但主要是因为我只是想玩得开心。而且我总是，每当我进入任何类型的布景，
I don't care what it is. If it's a Lego masters or animated show or a movie or TV show, my approach is always, I just came here to have fun and I'm not having fun. If you're not having fun, you know, you should bring some of that to the pot. Should I? Exactly. I don't care if there's one person in the audience or 450.
我不在乎它是什么。如果是《乐高大师》或者动画节目或者电影或电视节目，我的方法总是，我只是来这里玩得开心的，如果你们不开心，我就不开心。如果你不开心，你知道，你应该把一些带到锅里。我应该吗？没错。我不在乎观众席里是一个人还是450个人。
I get the same performance. That's not true. Is that what you're going to say next? I don't give the same performance. I don't either. Ever. But, but it is much more fun. It's, it's hard to do.
我得到同样的表演。那不是真的。那是你接下来要说的吗？我没有同样的表演。我也没有。从来没有。但，但它确实更有趣。它，它很难做。
You've done shows like that before. Like it's hard to do when you're just by yourself sometimes. Right. Well, when I get at home with Amy Sedaris and I play multiple characters, didn't it dawn on me? Oh, I have to memorize the other side of the script and their days. I'm just working by myself against, you know, myself. It was crazy.
你以前做过那样的节目。就像当你独自一人时有时很难做。对吧。好吧，当我在《与艾米·塞德丽丝在家》时，我扮演多个角色，我没意识到吗？哦，我必须背下剧本的另一面，而且是几天。我只是独自一人对着，你知道，我自己工作。这太疯狂了。
We should have filmed the making of that show. It was really funny what my stand ins had to put up with and what they had to do. You know, they've got their nose taped up and I'm like, oh, bless your heart. You don't have to take your nose up. Do you go crazy if you're not working? I like to work, but I'm okay not working right now. I've been doing voiceover stuff and I just did the Mandalorian, but, but I'm, but I'm okay with it.
我们应该拍下那个节目的制作过程。我的替身不得不忍受什么，他们不得不做什么，这真的很有趣。你知道，他们的鼻子被胶带贴住了，我就想，哦，保佑你的心。你不必把你的鼻子贴起来。如果你不工作，你会发疯吗？我喜欢工作，但我现在不工作也没关系。我一直在做配音工作，我刚做了《曼达洛人》，但，但我，但我没关系。
Sean says that you like to do crafts. Is that correct? And if so, what types of crafts really get you going? Is it involved hot glue gun? Yes. Before your answer, I wanted to say this because I was going to go there too, where Jason is going. Okay.
肖恩说你喜欢做手工。那是真的吗？如果是这样，什么类型的手工真的让你兴奋？它涉及热胶枪吗？是的。在回答之前，我想说这个，因为我也要往那里去，杰森要去的地方。好吧。
Your Instagram posts are legendary and I, I follow you like crazy. I love every single one. Every single one of them makes me laugh, even the ones that I'm not supposed to have. I follow you very casually. I'm so, I'm so afraid to get into Instagram. I feel like it could be a real K-hole for me. I've gotten a lot of really good ideas from Instagram. It's not so great right now, but I curate.
你的Instagram帖子是传奇，我，我疯狂地关注你。我喜欢每一个。每一个都让我笑，即使是我不应该有的那些。我非常随意地关注你。我太，我太害怕进入Instagram了。我觉得它对我来说可能是一个真正的K洞。我从Instagram上得到了很多非常好的想法。它现在不是那么好，但我策划。
I like, I post other people's stuff and then once in a while I post my own stuff. It's really good. I love it. It's really really good. One of the, one of the things I love that you do most is what's in the box. Oh. So, and you seem to have like an endless amount of box in your apartment. I know.
我喜欢，我发布别人的东西，然后偶尔我发布我自己的东西。它真的很好。我喜欢它。它真的真的很好。我最喜欢你做的事情之一是盒子里有什么。哦。所以，而且你的公寓里似乎有无穷无尽的盒子。我知道。
I have a lot more. Like Barbie doll parts and one was like velvet bows and miniature umbrellas. And I don't cook very often, but when I do, I use the potholders you made me. Oh. And yeah, I love those. So, but like to Jason's question, why, why crafts? Like what made you into crafting? Why, and teaching people craft?
我还有更多。像芭比娃娃零件，一个是天鹅绒蝴蝶结和微型雨伞。我不经常做饭，但当我做的时候，我用你给我做的隔热垫。哦。而且是的，我喜欢那些。所以，但对于杰森的问题，为什么，为什么做手工？是什么让你开始做手工的？为什么，还要教人们做手工？
You always look, make it look so fun. Well, I was in girl scouts till my senior year of high school and then I was in junior achievements and we were always making things and going door to door. You sound like a real hell cat. Sorry, keep going. Keep going. I love uniforms. I love uniforms.
你总是看起来，让它看起来很有趣。好吧，我在高中最后一年之前一直是女童子军，然后我在青年成就组织，我们总是做东西，挨家挨户地走。你听起来像个真正的泼妇。抱歉，继续。继续。我喜欢制服。我喜欢制服。
High school must have been crazy. I wore my uniform to school. Off the chain. Yeah. So, so there was a lot of crafts in girl scouts. There was a lot of crafts in girl scouts and a lot of drunk leaders, but I really liked, I like making stuff that's practical and I like doing something with my hands and, you know, cause your mind can wander.
高中一定很疯狂。我穿着制服去学校。脱离链条。是的。所以，所以女童子军里有很多手工。女童子军里有很多手工，还有很多喝醉的领队，但我真的很喜欢，我喜欢做实用的东西，我喜欢用我的手做点什么，而且，你知道，因为你的思想会游离。
But now after I did a craft book and the show, I mean, I really can't stand crafts and I hate it when someone makes me something and they give it to me because it's just like crap, nobody needs, you know, cause they have glitter on it. But if you make me pot holders or cover a lighter or, you know, what do you need? What do you do with all the crafts that you do make or have made? Do you, do you, isn't Etsy a spot where people sell stuff that they make? I usually wait till there's an audience and there's a table between me and the audience and I sell everything.
但现在，在我出了一本手工书并做了那个节目之后，我是说，我真的受不了手工，而且我讨厌别人给我做东西，因为那简直就是垃圾，没人需要，你知道，因为上面粘着亮片。但如果你给我做隔热垫，或者给打火机套个套子，或者，你知道，你需要什么？你对自己制作或曾经制作的所有手工艺品都怎么处理？Etsy 不是人们卖自己做东西的地方吗？我通常等到有观众，而且我和观众之间有一张桌子，然后我就把所有东西都卖掉。
Really? I can't even think or I'll bring someone, you know, from the theater and say, like, can you do this? You'll make 20 bucks and then you just sell this stuff. Like an adult lemonade stand. I have an adult lemonade stand. That's really. By the way, I have been to an, I went to an event once, I forget,
真的吗？我甚至没想过，或者我会带个人，你知道，从剧院里找个人，说，嘿，你能做这个吗？你能赚20块钱，然后你就把这些东西卖掉。就像成人的柠檬水摊。我有一个成人的柠檬水摊。那真是。顺便说一句，我曾经去过一个，我去过一个活动，我忘了，
it was for the, Justin was doing one of his sponsorship things. You know, he's always got with like a fancy watch or some company like that. And I show up at this thing downtown in New York and Amy was selling cupcakes. Oh, that's right. That's right. I remember that night. Yeah. I was in the cupcake and cheese ball business and then I got,
那是为了，贾斯汀在做他的赞助活动之一。你知道，他总是带着名表或者类似的公司。我出现在纽约市中心参加这个活动，艾米在卖纸杯蛋糕。哦，对了。没错。我记得那天晚上。是的。我当时在做纸杯蛋糕和奶酪球生意，然后我，
I had a mouse problem and then I got cockroaches and butter went up to eight bucks a pound. And I was like, fuck this shit. I'm not doing this anymore. But I will do special orders, but no repeat business and cash only. Does this make you a Martha Stewart fan or, or she the anti-Christ? You know, I, I was never inspired by Martha and I think because my stuff never looked like her stuff. I mean, it always looked too good and beautiful, but I was never, I just couldn't relate to
我遇到了老鼠问题，然后又有了蟑螂，黄油涨到了八块钱一磅。我就想，去他妈的。我不干了。但我会接受特殊订单，但不做回头客生意，而且只收现金。这让你成为玛莎·斯图尔特的粉丝了吗，还是她是反基督者？你知道，我，我从来没有被玛莎启发过，我想是因为我的东西看起来从来不像她的东西。我是说，她的东西总是看起来太好、太漂亮了，但我从来，我就是无法产生共鸣。
it. So my, my, I was inspired more by Galloping Gourmet, Frugal Gourmet, you know, Dinosaur, you know, people from the past, but my guess Martha knows what she's doing. How do you respond to people now with this newfound, this rivalry between you and Martha Stewart is what people are calling a feud. And some people are saying is getting very heated. What's your side of the group? No, that's not true.
所以我的，我的，我更多是受到《奔跑的美食家》、《节俭的美食家》，你知道，恐龙，你知道，过去那些人的启发，但我猜玛莎知道她在做什么。你现在如何回应人们关于你和玛莎·斯图尔特之间这种新发现的竞争，也就是人们所说的宿怨？有些人说这变得非常激烈。你对此怎么看？不，那不是真的。
I blame it all on flat foot Contessa. I like her voice. Do her voice. No, it's just soothing when you listen to it cause we would watch some of those shows, but it makes me nervous to watch the newer shows. I always like to go back and watch older stuff. Did you ever want to start like your own, forgive me if you have cause, and I don't know about it, but your own like line, like of stuff.
我把这一切都归咎于《赤脚主妇》。我喜欢她的声音。模仿一下她的声音。不，当你听的时候只是觉得很舒缓，因为我们会看那些节目，但看新节目让我感到紧张。我总是喜欢回去看旧的东西。你有没有想过开始像你自己的，如果我有的话请原谅我，我不知道，但你自己的那种，产品线。
Oh yeah. I would love my own house where, you know, sell curtains and toaster oven cozies and paper flowers. I need a new toaster oven cozy, but that's like people who say they want to farm with and never lived on a farm. They only want to have horses and goats. It would just be such a pain in the butt to be responsible for that too. Then I'm like, forget it and get high.
哦，是的。我很想要我自己的房子，你知道，卖窗帘、烤箱手套和纸花。我需要一个新的烤箱手套，但这就像那些说他们想去农场生活却从未在农场住过的人一样。他们只想要马和山羊。负责那些事情会很麻烦。然后我就想，算了吧，去嗨一下。
What do you think? If you had that toaster cozy business, what do you think you'd do with all the cash that you'd make from that? Yeah, you'd have to diversify your portfolio. I would hide it. I'd hide it in my apartment. Does your craft lust extend into cooking, gardening? Not gardening, but I cook every night for myself.
你怎么看？如果你有那个烤箱手套生意，你觉得你会怎么处理你赚到的所有现金？是的，你得分散你的投资组合。我会把它藏起来。我会把它藏在我的公寓里。你的手工欲望延伸到烹饪、园艺了吗？不是园艺，但我每天晚上都为自己做饭。
Every night? I'm always cooked. Everyone in my family cooks. You love to cook. Yeah. I'm into houseplants right now, but I'm not a gardener. I wouldn't know what to do in a garden. So who decides, like Sean, you asked me to be your guest.
每天晚上？我总是做饭。我家里每个人都做饭。你喜欢做饭。是的。我现在迷上了室内植物，但我不是园丁。我不知道在花园里该做什么。那么谁来决定，比如肖恩，你邀请我做你的嘉宾。
Whose turn is it next and how does this happen? Yeah. We haven't really done like, hey, Will, you're three light or I'm three heavy or something like that. It's just whoever has an idea and then we, then it's about, you know, booking y'all and trying to work around your schedules. That's kind of the biggest thing. You know, Amy, years ago, I don't know if you remember this years ago and you were
下一个轮到谁，这是怎么发生的？是的。我们并没有真正做过，嘿，威尔，你三号很轻松，或者我三号很忙之类的。这只是谁有个想法，然后我们，然后就是关于，你知道，预订你们，并试图配合你们的时间表。这算是最重要的事情。你知道，艾米，几年前，我不知道你是否还记得，几年前，你当时
busy. Like maybe you were starting to do one of your shows. I wanted to do a show and I called you. Oh yes. And I said, I want to do a cop show where you and I are partners. Do you remember this? This is like 10, over 10 years ago. And I called you up and I said, I'm so glad you don't remember because I remember
很忙。就像也许你刚开始做你的节目之一。我想做一个节目，我给你打了电话。哦，是的。我说，我想做一个警察节目，你和我搭档。你记得吗？这大概是10年前，超过10年前了。我给你打电话说，我很高兴你不记得了，因为我记得
it so vividly. I wanted to do a cop show where you were like the seasoned vet and you had no morals and no scruples and I was a rookie cop. And you were basically, it was kind of like, it was like this lawn or the whole thing was like about, you know, we show up at our first crime scene and you like literally put a gun in the guy's hand, the dead guy's hand and go, what are you doing? And you go, oh, what do you think we're going to do?
非常清楚。我想做一个警察节目，你是那种经验丰富的老手，没有道德，没有顾忌，而我是个菜鸟警察。你基本上，这有点像，就像《法律与秩序》，整个事情就是关于，你知道，我们出现在第一个犯罪现场，你真的把枪放在那个家伙手里，死人的手里，然后说，你在做什么？你说，哦，你以为我们要干什么？
Solve it? And then like, that's the cold open. Well, that sounds really funny. I know. That is funny. I really wanted to do it with you. And then you're like, I'm doing a craft show or something. You blew me off.
解决它？然后就像，那是冷开场。嗯，那听起来真的很有趣。我知道。那很有趣。我真的很想和你一起做。然后你说，我在做一个手工节目之类的。你把我打发了。
You blew me off. Craft show. Yeah. Amy, do you have a lot of dinner parties? Like, because you love to cook and stuff? I used to. And then a lot, you know, it cooked for 18 people in my tiny little kitchen. But then after I did the cookbook, I was like, I'm done entertaining.
你把我打发了。手工节目。是的。艾米，你经常举办晚宴吗？因为你喜欢做饭之类的？我以前常办。然后很多，你知道，在我的小厨房里为18个人做饭。但在我写完食谱后，我就想，我不再招待客人了。
Now it's more like one-on-one or like, if Sean, I know you can build shelves. I'm like, why don't you come over? I'll make dinner for you. You build these shelves for me. It's kind of like a little trade. Where do you get all this, all this energy, all this drive, all of this? Like, it doesn't sound like you're ever bored. Have you always had that kind of let's get after it mentality?
现在更多是一对一，或者如果肖恩，我知道你会做架子。我就想，你为什么不过来？我为你做晚饭。你为我做这些架子。这就像一个小交易。你从哪里得到所有这些，所有这些能量，所有这些动力，所有这些？听起来你从来不会感到无聊。你一直都有那种“让我们行动起来”的心态吗？
I don't know. I mean, it's easy to point and ask people to do stuff for you. I mean, I guess I have it. But then some days I'm like, God, I didn't do anything today. And then I'll sit down and write everything that I did. And I'm like, oh, I guess I did do a lot. You remind me a lot of Mark Wahlberg. You're like a real Mark Wahlberg.
我不知道。我是说，指使别人为你做事很容易。我是说，我想我有。但有时我会想，天哪，我今天什么都没做。然后我会坐下来写下我所做的一切。然后我就想，哦，我想我确实做了很多。你让我想起了马克·沃尔伯格。你就像一个真正的马克·沃尔伯格。
You and he are like the busiest people. Do you get that all the time, Amy? I get that all the time. No, it's true. Do you ever like, I think I asked you this at the top, but do you do anything to just calm down and just like vegetate? My stretching class on Saturdays. Right, right, right.
你和他一样是世界上最忙的人。你经常听到这个吗，艾米？我经常听到这个。不，这是真的。你有没有，我想我在开头问过你，但你有没有做过什么来让自己冷静下来，就像植物人一样？我周六的拉伸课。对，对，对。
But is that the only thing? You get into the jazz cigarettes, don't you? I get into the jazz cigarettes to calm down. You know, I'll go for a walk. I see David a lot. He has a place on the Upper East Side. So that's been really nice. I'll invite myself for dinner all the time.
但那是唯一的事情吗？你开始抽爵士香烟了，不是吗？我开始抽爵士香烟来冷静下来。你知道，我会去散步。我经常见到大卫。他在上东区有个住处。所以那真的很不错。我会一直不请自来去吃晚饭。
And I'll go, you know, over there. David walks like 30 miles a day or something ridiculous. And then he goes back out after midnight. Really? I don't walk as much as David, but yeah, he's always walking, listens to a lot of podcasts and books on tape. That's nice. What's the foot traffic like in New York right now with COVID?
我会去，你知道，那边。大卫每天走大概30英里或者类似荒谬的距离。然后他在午夜之后又出去了。真的吗？我走得没有大卫多，但是的，他一直在走路，听很多播客和有声书。那很好。纽约现在的步行交通状况如何，因为新冠疫情？
Is it starting to become more and more populated out there on the street now? Yes. It's getting busier and busier. Restaurants are open. Is everyone wearing masks while they're walking? Everyone's wearing a mask. I was in North Carolina recently. A lot of people weren't wearing masks.
街上现在开始变得越来越拥挤了吗？是的。越来越忙了。餐馆都开了。大家走路时都戴口罩吗？每个人都戴着口罩。我最近在北卡罗来纳州。很多人没戴口罩。
And I was in Kentucky and nobody was wearing masks. How'd you feel about that? It's just put a fucking mask on. It's like, what's so hard about it really? Let me ask you this, Amy. And this is, again, controversial. The term Karen that's been used a lot in the last year. It's been very thrown around and very loosely, I might add.
我在肯塔基州，没人戴口罩。你对此感觉如何？就是戴上该死的口罩。就像，这真的有什么难的吗？让我问你这个，艾米。这又是，有争议的。过去一年里经常使用的“凯伦”这个词。它被到处乱用，而且我得补充说，非常随意。
Do you... Wait, who was that for two seconds? That was a totally different kind. I know. Amy, if you could, have all the Karen's that have emerged via social media and everywhere, has it just given you a lot of ideas for new characters? Yes. I mean, someone's got to be doing a Karen movie.
你……等等，那两秒钟是谁？那是完全不同的一种。我知道。艾米，如果你能，通过社交媒体和各地涌现的所有“凯伦”，它是否给了你很多新角色的灵感？是的。我是说，肯定有人得拍一部“凯伦”电影。
Absolutely. Every time I saw all these videos and people would use the term Karen and I'd see these videos, I think like, now they're Amy Sedaris character. Come on. Don't you think someone's working on a Karen movie? They've got to be. Yeah, it's a great idea. They're just fascinating me.
绝对的。每次我看到所有这些视频，人们使用“凯伦”这个词，我看到这些视频，我想，现在她们是艾米·塞达里斯的角色。得了吧。你不觉得有人在拍“凯伦”电影吗？他们一定在拍。是的，这是个好主意。她们让我着迷。
It's a great title. I love anyone who complains, who bitches, who... I just can't get enough of that. Yeah. I love it. I love it. Fuck, man. I tell you what, we did this semi-pro movie years ago with Will Ferrell
这是一个很棒的标题。我喜欢任何抱怨、发牢骚的人，谁……我就是看不够。是的。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。该死，伙计。我告诉你，我们几年前和威尔·法瑞尔拍了那部《半职业选手》电影，
and a bunch of guys in Woody Harrelson and Amy, we were watching this background actor and she was blonde hair. Oh, right. She's like similar stature. Do you remember this? Yes, I do. Right. So for like a couple of weeks, we were watching me and Andy Daly and Will and Andy Richter
还有伍迪·哈里森和艾米，我们当时在看那个背景演员，她是金发。哦，对了。她身材差不多。你记得吗？是的，我记得。对。所以大概几个星期，我们一直在看，我和安迪·戴利、威尔和安迪·里希特，
and we were laughing. We were like, this is such an Amy Sedaris character. And then Ken Ultraman, the director, one day when Amy came on to shoot some stuff, he goes, you got to get down to set right now because Amy's talking to the woman right now. Because we pointed her out and then Amy went and had a long conversation with her. Remember, she was in character. What were you talking to her about, Amy?
我们在笑。我们说，这真是个艾米·塞达里斯式的角色。然后肯·奥特曼，导演，有一天当艾米来拍一些东西时，他说，你现在得下到片场，因为艾米正在和那个女人说话。因为我们指出了她，然后艾米就去和她进行了长时间的交谈。记得吗，她当时在角色里。你在和她聊什么，艾米？
I don't remember what we talked about, but I did. I embraced her. I went right to her. You went right to her. That's usually who I go to. I love that. Amy, you've done like so, so, so many things in your life in this business. Is there anything that you want to achieve that you haven't yet?
我不记得我们聊了什么，但我确实。我拥抱了她。我直接走向她。你直接走向她。那通常是我会去找的人。我喜欢那个。艾米，你在这一行里做了这么多，这么多，这么多事情。有什么你想实现但还没实现的吗？
Like, is there any? I want to have a baby. I want to have a baby. You want to have a baby? No, I don't want to have a baby. I can't at my age, but I just turned 60. So now I'm old. I know you did it.
比如，有什么吗？我想生个孩子。我想生个孩子。你想生个孩子？不，我不想生孩子。我这个年纪生不了了，但我刚满60岁。所以现在我老了。我知道你做到了。
Now I'm old. I'm for old people. I'm young, but I'm for young people. I'm very old. Wait a second. You're not 60. I just turned 60. You're kidding.
现在我老了。我是为老年人准备的。我很年轻，但我适合年轻人。我非常老。等一下。你没60岁。我刚满60岁。你在开玩笑。
That's the new 40. It's the new 40. It is. You, I mean, again, you look amazing. Oh, thank you. But yeah, 60. How about that? So what can I do at 60?
那是新的40岁。那是新的40岁。确实。你，我是说，再说一次，你看上去棒极了。哦，谢谢。但确实，60岁。那怎么样？所以我60岁能做什么？
I guess now I can start playing, because I always played older people. I liked playing older, but now that I'm older, maybe now I can play teenagers. Maybe. I love that. Is there somebody you haven't worked with that you like would kill to work with? Say Jason. Say Jason. Say Jason.
我想现在我可以开始演了，因为我总是演老年人。我喜欢演老年人，但现在我老了，也许现在我可以演青少年了。也许吧。我喜欢那个。有没有你还没合作过但你非常想合作的人？说杰森。说杰森。说杰森。
Um, besides Jason and Will and of course yourself, John Milkovich, we wanted on our show. Oh my gosh. I was just talking about him yesterday. Really? Why? Because he's one of the acting shops to work with him. But I want to watch him or you know, I don't. But boy, I loved John Milkovich and I like his choices.
嗯，除了杰森和威尔，当然还有你自己，约翰·马尔科维奇，我们想让他上我们的节目。哦，天哪。我昨天还在谈论他。真的吗？为什么？因为他是那种值得合作的演技派。但我只是想看他，或者你知道，我不。但天哪，我喜欢约翰·马尔科维奇，我喜欢他的选择。
He's like one of the, he is, he's like top three actors in the world as far as I'm concerned. Yeah. But outside of the business, is there something you always like, I want a skydive. I want to fucking, you know, I'm sure there's something. Have my little store, my houseware store. Yeah, I would help you with that. Would you get bored of that?
他就像其中之一，他是，在我看来他是世界上前三名的演员。是的。但在工作之外，有没有什么你一直想，我想跳伞。我想该死的，你知道，我相信肯定有什么。拥有我的小店，我的家居用品店。是的，我会帮你那个。你会对此感到无聊吗？
Do you think? Yes, probably. Can I help you find something? No, I'm just looking. Great. I'm here if you need my help. I feel like your story would be filled with so like every day would be new items and then like you'd go and you'd be like, it'd be like 2pm.
你觉得呢？是的，可能会。我可以帮你找点什么吗？不，我只是看看。太好了。如果你需要帮助，我就在这里。我觉得你的店会装满，就像每天都会有新商品，然后就像，你会去，你会觉得，就像下午2点。
You'd be like, is this store now we're closed. Wait, it says you're up until six. Well, we closed today. Change your mind. What about golf? You want to, you want to become a golfer? I took off lessons. I like the golf shoes and that's why I took the lessons.
你会说，这家店现在关门了。等等，上面写着你营业到六点。嗯，我们今天关门了。改变主意了。高尔夫怎么样？你想，你想成为一名高尔夫球手吗？我上了高尔夫课。我喜欢高尔夫球鞋，这就是我上课的原因。
But I was like, oh, this is so boring. You talking about golf. You talking about the shoes with the little fan that's on the top that goes over the laces and the spikes on the bottom. Yes, I love that. Yeah. Yeah. I love golf shoes.
但我当时想，哦，这太无聊了。你在谈论高尔夫。你在谈论鞋面上那个盖住鞋带的小扇子和底部的钉子。是的，我喜欢那个。是的。是的。我喜欢高尔夫球鞋。
And then they could double as tap shoes. They could. Yeah. I'll bet you tap dance. Do you know how to tap dance? I'll bet you do. You know, I had the energy to top. I bet I would have been great at tap dancer.
而且它们可以兼作踢踏舞鞋。它们可以。是的。我敢打赌你会跳踢踏舞。你知道怎么跳踢踏舞吗？我敢打赌你会。你知道，我有跳踢踏舞的精力。我敢打赌我本来会是个很棒的踢踏舞者。
I mean, I can just fake it, but I don't, I wish I had taken tap lenses when I was little or a dance class or something. It's never too late. Amy, you and Dave Letterman have and have had a kind of awesome relationships, certainly on the surface in terms of when he had his show and you would come on a lot and you would contribute, you'd go and you'd do stuff for him and you'd be a guest all the time. What was that like? Oh my God, you were always so funny.
我是说，我可以假装，但我没有，我希望我小时候上过踢踏舞课，或者舞蹈课之类的。永远都不晚。艾米，你和大卫·莱特曼有，而且一直有一种很棒的关系，当然是在表面上，就当他有节目时，你会经常去，你会做出贡献，你会去为他做些事情，而且你一直都是嘉宾。那是什么感觉？哦，天哪，你总是那么有趣。
I liked doing it because a lot of times it was because someone canceled and so they would call me up. You know, I always had a dress hanging up. So I always knew what I wanted to wear. And then I would go there and because I liked being called last minute because it's like, hey, what do you expect? I didn't have time to prepare. You know, you kind of fall back on that.
我喜欢这样做，因为很多时候是因为有人取消了，所以他们会打电话给我。你知道，我总是挂着一件礼服。所以我总是知道我想穿什么。然后我会去那里，因为我喜欢被临时叫去，因为就像，嘿，你期待什么？我没时间准备。你知道，你有点依赖那个。
But I always had a notebook and I would always write down, you know, this might be good for Letterman or that might be good for Letterman. But then it was interesting. He'd start coming in the wings, back to the wings and say hi to me before the show. And that always made me really nervous because it's like, oh my God. And then I had a meeting with him once. We were thinking about doing, he wanted me to come up with a show idea for him. And I remember saying, he goes, what don't you want?
但我总是有一个笔记本，我总是会写下来，你知道，这可能对莱特曼有好处，或者那个可能对莱特曼有好处。但后来很有趣。他开始来到侧台，回到侧台，在节目开始前跟我打招呼。那总是让我非常紧张，因为就像，哦，天哪。然后我有一次和他开会。我们当时在考虑做，他想让我为他想一个节目点子。我记得我说，他说，你不想要什么？
And I always liked that question because I never knew what I wanted, but I always knew what I didn't want. Let's hear it. What don't you want to do with the rest of your life? Well, just TV show. Like I just knew that now I don't remember back in the day what it was, but I was just afraid of doing a TV show back then when he asked me to do one with his production company. I didn't really have any really good ideas.
我一直喜欢那个问题，因为我从来不知道我想要什么，但我总是知道我不想要什么。让我们听听。你余生不想做什么？嗯，只是电视节目。就像我只是知道现在我不记得当时是什么了，但我当时很害怕做电视节目，当他让我用他的制作公司做一个时。我真的没有任何真正好的点子。
But you were intimidated? I mean, yeah, I mean with Letterman. Well, I was, I told the story about Amy. One of my first times going on there, you were the lead guest. And I was so nervous because he was Dave Letterman. He was my comedy hero. And you were like, I guess maybe you were filling in. Maybe it was last minute, as you said, but anyway, because you were on there, you were
但你被吓到了？我是说，是的，我是说和莱特曼一起。嗯，我当时，我讲过关于艾米的故事。我第一次去那里时，你是首席嘉宾。我非常紧张，因为他是大卫·莱特曼。他是我的喜剧英雄。而你就像，我猜也许你是替补。也许是最后一分钟，正如你所说的，但无论如何，因为你在那里，你
very loose and you weren't really promoting anything. Never. And you were just, yeah, ever. And you were chit chatting with him. And then you said, oh yeah, your next guest is Will Arnett. And you were really nice to about me to him on stage and you totally relaxed me and made me feel so good. Oh, that's nice.
非常放松，你并没有真正宣传任何东西。从来没有。而且你只是，是的，从来没有。而且你在和他闲聊。然后你说，哦，是的，你的下一位嘉宾是威尔·阿奈特。你在台上对他评价我非常好，你完全让我放松了，让我感觉非常好。哦，那真好。
I actually, I remember that. I was so nervous and it was a very kind thing of you to do. Most times you went on there. There was no pre-interview. There was nothing planned. No, we would do a pre-interview. Oh, you would? But they would ask me last minute, so and so canceled or like one time Condoleezza Rice
我实际上，我记得那个。我当时非常紧张，你那样做非常友善。大多数时候你去那里。没有预采访。没有计划好的事情。不，我们会做预采访。哦，你们会？但他们会最后一分钟问我，某某取消了，或者像有一次康多莉扎·赖斯
was on. She chewed up the whole segment, you know, so. Oh, can she go on? She went on and on. So I was out there for like three minutes, but Letterman called me that night to apologize. And I thought, oh my God, I was like, and I didn't pick up the phone. I was like, and then he called me out on it. And he goes, why didn't you pick up the phone?
在上面。她嚼碎了整个环节，你知道，所以。哦，她能上吗？她没完没了。所以我大概在那待了三分钟，但莱特曼那天晚上打电话给我道歉。我想，哦，天哪，我当时想，而且我没接电话。我当时想，然后他为此指责我。他说，你为什么不接电话？
I was like, there's no way I'm going to pick up the phone and talk to you at 9.30 at night. I was like, oh my God, there's, I just couldn't do it. And he goes, well, how do you think that made me feel? I really wanted to talk to you and apologize to you and you didn't allow me that. And I was like, well, call me now. Call me tomorrow night. Jesus. Yeah, I think that, I think that Sean's sister in Wisconsin would be surprised to learn that,
我当时想，我不可能在晚上9点半接电话和你说话。我当时想，哦，天哪，我就是做不到。他说，好吧，你觉得那让我感觉如何？我真的很想和你说话并向你道歉，而你没给我那个机会。我当时想，好吧，现在给我打电话。明天晚上给我打电话。天哪。是的，我想，我想肖恩在威斯康星州的姐姐会惊讶地发现，
that every single time a guest is on a talk show, it is pre-planned. There is a whole pre-interview that goes on and you know the question and you work out the answer. Now, oftentimes if you've got the skills of the three of you, you will go off of that and start to sort of vamp and kind of freestyle a bit. But for the, for the most part, it's, it's all scripted. Well, then sometimes Letterman wouldn't stick to the questions. He never did. He never did. Or you had your secret list and you knew we were going to bring something up because if you asked if you could say it,
每次嘉宾上脱口秀节目，都是预先计划好的。有一个完整的预采访，你知道问题，并制定出答案。现在，通常如果你有你们三个人的技巧，你会脱离那个，开始即兴发挥。但大部分情况下，这都是写好的。嗯，有时莱特曼不会坚持问题。他从来没有。他从来没有。或者你有你的秘密清单，你知道我们要提出一些事情，因为如果你问如果你能说出来，
they'll like, oh, no, no, do that. So, you know, I always had my little B cheat sheet in my book. Letterman, Letterman would always, like, you have the question. He never gets it. And then he'd always want to ask me like if I was still smoking and then I would, I would end up devolving into me doing like miming how it's different, different ways of stubbing on a cigarette. I'll be right there. That's hilarious.
他们会说，哦，不，不，做那个。所以，你知道，我总是把我的小B作弊条放在我的书里。莱特曼，莱特曼总是会，就像，你有问题。他从来没得到。然后他总是想问我是否还在抽烟，然后我最终会演变成我模仿不同方式掐灭香烟。我就在那儿。那太搞笑了。
I do miss him. And I haven't seen his new show, but I miss him. And I like to be nervous, you know, for sometimes I would get very eager to do a show. And, but I don't really get nervous for on other people's talk shows. If somebody sits you today, listen, Amy, we wanted you to come and do the show, a TV show. And it's the show that you really want to do. It's an idea that you really love with a bunch of people that you'd love to spend time with. But you've got to come to Los Angeles to do it and it's going to be a four year commitment.
我确实想念他。我还没看过他的新节目，但我很想念他。我喜欢紧张，你知道，有时我会非常渴望做一个节目。但是，在别人的脱口秀节目上我真的不会紧张。如果今天有人坐下来，听着，艾米，我们想让你来做这个节目，一个电视节目。这是你真正想做的节目。这是一个你真正喜欢的点子，和一群你喜欢共度时光的人。但你必须去洛杉矶做它，而且这是一个四年的承诺。
Oh my goodness. Oh my God. He's about to offer you something. Sounds like it. I would have a tough time doing that. I would have a hard time doing that, I think. Because I'm, you know, my best friend, Paul D'Anello's here and he's got kids and Godmother, which is a full time job. Yeah.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。他正要给你提供什么东西。听起来是这样。我会很难做到这一点。我想我会很难做到这一点。因为我，你知道，我最好的朋友保罗·达内洛在这里，他有孩子，教母，这是一份全职工作。是的。
Yeah. What is that? What does that job entail? I've talked about this before. I was made Godfather twice and I haven't ever done anything. In fact, I can't even remember the second kid that I am the Godfather of. I know the first one, but I can't remember which. They're so happy to hear that.
是的。那是什么？那份工作需要什么？我以前谈过这个。我被两次选为教父，但我从来没做过任何事。事实上，我甚至不记得我是第二个孩子的教父。我知道第一个，但我记不清是哪个。他们听到这个很高兴。
Well, that kid feels good right now. Yeah. But I was never really told what the duties are and so I never do anything. You're in charge of their spiritual growth. Truly? Yeah. I'm not allowed to babysit. Trust me with the kids on my own, but I, you know, I'm a really good Godmother and it's a full time job.
嗯，那个孩子现在感觉很好。是的。但我从来没被真正告知职责是什么，所以我从来不做任何事。你负责他们的精神成长。真的吗？是的。我不被允许做保姆。相信我独自照顾孩子，但我，你知道，我是一个非常好的教母，这是一份全职工作。
But literally, is that really the duty is sort of spiritual guide or aren't you just supposed to catch them financially and otherwise if the parents die in a fiery crash? Yes. And Paul and D'Anello were traveling together somewhere and I said, so if you're going together, you know, we should get it on paper that the kids, I've got to take care and they weren't even going to use me for that. They were like, no way. And I was like, are you kidding me? Like, I thought that was my job. Scotty and I are very proud Godparents to Jonah and Sammy.
但字面上，那真的是职责吗，某种精神向导，还是如果父母在火灾中丧生，你不应该在经济上和其他方面接手他们吗？是的。保罗和达内洛当时一起去某个地方旅行，我说，所以如果你们一起去，你知道，我们应该把它写在纸上，孩子们，我得照顾，他们甚至没打算用我做那个。他们说，没门。我当时想，你在开玩笑吗？就像，我以为那是我的工作。斯科蒂和我非常自豪能成为乔纳和萨米的教父母。
And one goes to NYU and one's about to go to college. And yes, Jason, we actually had assigned papers to, if something should happen, we have to raise them. But they're almost adults and on their own. But is that the full extent of it or do you have to do other things? It depends. I'm a Godfather to my nephew who is now about to turn 19. Wait, so you're an uncle and a Godfather to the same person? Yeah, that's right.
一个去了纽约大学，一个快要上大学了。是的，杰森，我们实际上不得不签署文件，如果发生什么事，我们必须抚养他们。但他们快成年了，可以自立了。但这就是全部吗，还是你必须做其他事情？这取决于。我是我侄子的教父，他现在快19岁了。等等，所以你是同一个人的叔叔和教父？是的，没错。
And I send them, you know, you get gifts and you also spend time and you every once in a while, they, you know, you, I was lucky enough, I had two, three great Godparents actually, two men and a gal and two of them are still alive and really important parts of my life. They were really good to me. I spent a lot of time with them. They gave me a lot of guidance. But how is that different than the presumed duties as an uncle? Good question. We'll be right back. Oh, shit.
我给他们寄，你知道，你得到礼物，你也花时间，你每隔一段时间，他们，你知道，我足够幸运，我实际上有三个很棒的教父母，两个男人和一个女人，其中两个还活着，是我生活中非常重要的一部分。他们对我真的很好。我花了很多时间和他们在一起。他们给了我很多指导。但这和作为叔叔的推定职责有什么不同？好问题。我们马上回来。哦，该死。
Are we going to commercials? No commercials. I'm still laughing at it's a full time job. It is. I would do it. I would do shows on my computer, like, you know, I, whatever you call it, and I would entertain them and I'd have different hats and teeth and do a little morning show for them. How old are they? Nine and six.
我们要进广告了吗？没有广告。我还在笑“这是一份全职工作”。确实是。我会做到的。我会在我的电脑上做节目，就像，你知道，无论你叫它什么，我会娱乐他们，我会戴不同的帽子和牙齿，为他们做一个小晨间节目。他们多大了？九岁和六岁。
Okay. That makes sense. But I bring out, when I go to Maplewood, that's where they live. I bring their favorite, you know, food and candy and I get them hopped up on sugar. You know, we watch movies together and because I'm in Mandalorian, all the kids in the neighborhood really, you know, a big deal. This sounds less like you going the extra mile and more like the parents aren't doing shit. That's what it sounds like. I'm like, can I come out today?
好的。那说得通。但我带出来，当我去枫木镇时，那是他们住的地方。我带他们最喜欢的，你知道，食物和糖果，我让他们沉迷于糖。你知道，我们一起看电影，因为我在《曼达洛人》里，附近所有的孩子真的，你知道，大人物。这听起来不像你付出了额外的努力，更像是父母什么都没做。听起来是这样。我就像，我今天能出来吗？
They're like, oh, they know what that entails. But the best thing you can do is give them the day off. Amy, I'm so struck with, you know, we've hung out a couple of times, but I don't think we've ever spent a full hour. And I'm so struck by your spirit. I'm envious of it. I admire it. Does it ever wane? I mean, you strike me as somebody who is very consistent with that spirit.
他们就像，哦，他们知道那意味着什么。但你能做的最好的事情就是给他们放一天假。艾米，我真的很受，你知道，我们聚过几次，但我不认为我们花过整整一个小时。我真的很受你的精神感染。我很羡慕它。我很钦佩它。它会减弱吗？我是说，你给我的印象是一个精神非常一致的人。
Does anything ever get you down or pissed off? I can't imagine you angry. Right. I mean, sure. I get angry. I get mad. It doesn't last long. I don't hold grudges.
有什么事情会让你沮丧或生气吗？我无法想象你生气。对。我是说，当然。我生气。我发火。它不会持续太久。我不记仇。
What does it for you? Can we see that? Can you raise your voice and show us a little? You know, someone walking down the street with pulling luggage behind them or, you know, typical. Wait a second. Anyone pulling fucking luggage behind them on the sidewalk will set you off? Well, in New York. Yes, or they're coming.
什么会让你那样？我们能看看吗？你能提高嗓门给我们展示一下吗？你知道，有人走在街上拖着行李，或者，你知道，典型的。等一下。任何在人行道上拖着该死的行李的人都会让你发火？嗯，在纽约。是的，或者他们来了。
I mean, oh, sure. They're coming on the left side. I have a list on my computer of things that annoy me. And sometimes I go, whenever I get mad at something, it goes on this master list that I have. And it could be just stupid stuff, but I just get so mad that I have to write it down. I love sidewalk etiquette. It's the worst. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我是说，哦，当然。他们从左边来。我的电脑上有一个让我烦恼的事情清单。有时我去，每当我因为某事生气时，它就会进入我拥有的这个总清单。这可能只是愚蠢的事情，但我就是太生气了，我必须把它写下来。我喜欢人行道礼仪。这是最糟糕的。是的，是的，是的。
I just picked up on that. That's a New York thing. So left side, there is their lanes on the sidewalk. Right on the right side. Just walk on the right. And don't meander in the middle. Like on your phone fucking taking up the entire side. Oh, I let people walk into me.
我刚注意到那个。那是纽约的事情。所以左边，人行道上有车道。右边在右边。就在右边走。不要在中间漫步。就像在你的手机上该死地占据了整个侧面。哦，我让人们撞到我。
I just let them walk into me and then they get mad at me because I did that. It's like, or when you get changed and they put the receipt in, you know, little things like that just send me off. And I get really angry. Oh my God. Will you please write a small book of that? Well, I thought, why isn't somebody done something like that? New York City etiquette book. You should do a New York City etiquette book.
我只是让他们撞到我，然后他们因为我那样做而对我生气。就像，或者当你找零钱时，他们把收据放进去，你知道，像那样的小事就会让我发火。我真的很生气。哦，天哪。你能写一本关于那个的小书吗？嗯，我想，为什么没人做过那样的事情？纽约市礼仪书。你应该写一本纽约市礼仪书。
Just call it, I'm pissed off. This is stuff to read on the crapper. You know, if you're not working on your golf swing, you can read this book about, you know, things that piss you off. Oh, that's good. You already know what your demographic that you're going for is, is people on the crapper. That's nice. And another thing. I wrote down, I did, you know, I did Broadway for a year in 2010 and I wrote down all the shit I hate about New York.
就叫它，“我生气了”。这是在马桶上读的东西。你知道，如果你不在练习高尔夫挥杆，你可以读这本书，关于，你知道，让你生气的事情。哦，那很好。你已经知道你的目标人群是马桶上的人了。那很好。还有一件事。我写下来了，我确实，你知道，我在2010年演了一年的百老汇，我写下了所有我讨厌纽约的事情。
And I can't find it, but it's really good. Well, I went to go see your play and I did the thing that people hate hearing is like, how did you memorize all that stuff? But I'm amazed by that because I just don't know how people memorize. I think it's so, it's just so hard to memorize stuff. You've got a 90 minute show to memorize. How did you do that? Just page by page. I mean, you may, you set little goals.
我找不到它，但它真的很好。嗯，我去看你的戏了，我做了人们讨厌听的事情，就像，你是怎么记住所有那些东西的？但我对此感到惊讶，因为我就是不知道人们是怎么记忆的。我觉得这太，这太难记忆了。你有一个90分钟的节目要记忆。你是怎么做到的？一页一页地。我是说，你，你设定小目标。
So the whole script was 45 pages. And I said, by this date, I'm like 15 pages memorize. And we'll be right back. Yeah, exactly. We're done. That's it. Sorry. I fell asleep while you were talking about your process.
所以整个剧本是45页。我说，到这个日期，我大概记住了15页。我们马上回来。是的，没错。我们完成了。就是这样。抱歉。你在谈论你的过程时我睡着了。
It's out of the audience. I always want a present for memorizing my lines. I'm always like, I memorized this, John. You're going to give me a present. Yeah. That's fair. I think that's fair. I want to echo what Jason said, which is that I also have always been in awe of your spirit.
那是观众。我总是想要一份记忆台词的礼物。我总是说，我记住了这个，约翰。你要给我一份礼物。是的。这很公平。我想这很公平。我想呼应杰森所说的，那就是我也一直对你的精神感到敬畏。
I think that you're one of those people. You always bring it. You're so consistently funny. You're so naturally funny. And kind. It's true. You're one of those people you have no choice in the matter. You're funny whether you like it or not.
我想你是那种人。你总是全力以赴。你总是那么一致地有趣。你天生就那么有趣。而且善良。这是真的。你是那种你别无选择的人。无论你喜不喜欢，你都很有趣。
And you're one of those people everybody agrees is great. Yeah. And you're organic about it. And you are who you are. And I fucking love it. And I really, really, really, really, really think that you're awesome. Yes. And I always have.
而且你是那种每个人都同意很棒的人。是的。而且你对此很自然。你就是你。我他妈的喜欢它。我真的，真的，真的，真的，真的认为你很棒。是的。我一直都这么认为。
Thank you. Here comes the butt. Here comes the butt. I have notes. However. Having said all that. What is your problem? Here's a list of improvements.
谢谢。屁股来了。屁股来了。我有笔记。然而。说了这么多。你有什么问题？这是一份改进清单。
First of all, when you get up in the morning. Oh, needs improvement. Just take my phone call next time when I say we're going to do a buddy cop show. Come on. Yeah. And Amy, I have deep, deep, deep love for you. I think you know that. I just appreciate you so much on so many levels.
首先，当你早上起床时。哦，需要改进。下次我说我们要拍一部搭档警察节目时，接我的电话。得了吧。是的，艾米，我对你有深深的，深深的，深深的爱。我想你知道这一点。我在很多层面上都非常欣赏你。
So thanks for being here. Thanks for giving some of your spirit to us. Oh, thank you. Thanks for asking me. I listened to your show. I love it. Sean, because you've emailed me. We had this podcast.
所以谢谢你来到这里。谢谢你给我们一些你的精神。哦，谢谢。谢谢你邀请我。我听了你的节目。我喜欢它。肖恩，因为你给我发了邮件。我们有这个播客。
It's like, I know your podcast. I listened to it. It's so funny. Like, I don't know if you remember me. I was on Will and Grace. I'm like, oh, please. Well, I don't want to keep you from your Saturday. Oh, yeah.
就像，我知道你的播客。我听了。它太有趣了。就像，我不知道你是否记得我。我上过《威尔和格蕾丝》。我就像，哦，拜托。嗯，我不想耽误你的周六。哦，是的。
Right. You've got lots of running around more stretching to do. Reach for those stars. Keep reaching for them. All right. Thanks so much for having me on. Thank you, Amy. Nice to see all of you.
对。你还有很多跑腿和拉伸要做。去摘那些星星吧。继续去摘它们。好的。非常感谢邀请我。谢谢你，艾米。很高兴见到你们所有人。
You too. You too. Enjoy the rest of your weekend. You too. Bye. So, Jayce, I thought you, I thought you knew her really. I thought you guys used to hang out or something, or like you knew her from something.
你也是。你也是。享受周末剩下的时光。你也是。再见。所以，杰斯，我以为你，我以为你真的认识她。我以为你们以前常在一起玩之类的，或者就像你从什么地方认识她。
Me and Amy? Yeah. No. Why would you think that? I mean, I wish. No, because of Thoreau. Same circles, I guess. Oh, because of Thoreau.
我和艾米？是的。不。你为什么会那样想？我是说，我希望。不，因为梭罗。我想是同一个圈子。哦，因为梭罗。
You know, what I was going to say about her relationship with Thoreau is that I really envy their friendship. I don't have a super close girl friend. I never have. I can be that for you. I don't know what that is. Yeah. I mean, aside from you, Sean.
你知道，关于她和梭罗的关系，我想说的是，我真的很羡慕他们的友谊。我没有一个超级亲密的女性朋友。我从来没有。我可以为你做那个。我不知道那是什么。是的。我是说，除了你，肖恩。
Just someone that you can go to, you can turn to and just kind of say, hey, girlfriend, like, you know, whatever. Gal Pal is what I like. Yeah. Hey, girl. No, they have, they have a really, a really deep friendship.
只是一个你可以去找，你可以转向，然后说，嘿，女朋友，就像，你知道，无论什么。我喜欢“闺蜜”这个词。是的。嘿，女孩。不，她们有，她们有非常，非常深厚的友谊。
And if I were to have one, it would be someone like Amy Sedaris. I would only hope. Yeah. I think, I think lots of people feel that way. She's one of those people who emit kind of this, where I, like I said, where everybody can agree, oh, we all love Amy Sedaris.
如果我要有一个，那会是像艾米·塞达里斯这样的人。我只能希望。是的。我想，我想很多人都有这种感觉。她是那种散发出这种，就像我说的，每个人都能同意，哦，我们都爱艾米·塞达里斯的人。
She's the best. I love her. I wish, I wish I knew her better. We've hung out a few times over the years, but like Justin would tell these great stories of like, walking in the, they'd be like in the pharmacy and she'd grab like a big pack of like the pens, you know, adult diapers and she'd go,
她是最好的。我爱她。我希望，我希望我更了解她。这些年来我们聚过几次，但就像贾斯汀会讲这些很棒的故事，就像，走进药店，她会抓起一大包，你知道，成人尿布，她会说，
Justin, they do have them in your size. Like across the thing, super loud. She's so funny, man. Wow. She's so funny. She's so, so funny. She'd like walk down the street and litter, you know, like on purpose.
贾斯汀，他们确实有你的尺码。就像穿过那个东西，超级大声。她太有趣了，伙计。哇。她太有趣了。她太，太有趣了。她会像走在街上乱扔垃圾，你知道，就像故意的。
Obviously go back and get it for all the people who are going to. Yeah. She's got that real sunny disposition, but you can tell that you don't have to dig very deep to access any sort of darkness or sarcasm or edge to her humor. Like she gets it all, but you know, it's, it's there. It's there if you want it. She chooses the sunny side of the street.
显然回去为所有那些要……的人捡回来。是的。她有那种真正阳光的性格，但你可以看出你不需要挖掘得很深就能接触到她幽默中的任何黑暗、讽刺或边缘。就像她都懂，但你知道，它，它就在那里。如果你想要，它就在那里。她选择了街道阳光明媚的一面。
I think that's part of her secret. I love that. And she is so profoundly funny. I meant to like, you know, she is, she's one of those people. Like she can't, when she was, when she would go out with Thoreau, instead of like holding up something and, and joking about like getting it for him, would she ever actually buy something for him?
我想那是她秘密的一部分。我喜欢那个。而且她非常深刻地有趣。我本想，你知道，她是，她是那种人。就像她不能，当她，当她和梭罗出去时，而不是像举起什么东西，开玩笑说要为他买，她真的会为他买什么吗？
Bye. Oh, bye. Oh, bye. Bye. Bye. That was pretty good, Sean. Bye. Smart.
再见。哦，再见。哦，再见。再见。再见。那很不错，肖恩。再见。聪明。
Right. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart.
对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。
Right. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。